BLACK PRESIDENT IN PART.
>> Sean: THERE IS THE GLARING DO
YOU BELIEVE STANDARD.
MEDIA RESEARCH CENTER SAID 90%
OF THE COVERAGE ON THE 3 BIG
DESPITE ALL OF THAT THE
PRESIDENT CONTINUES TO STAY
FOCUSSED AND IS WORKING HARD AND
PUSHING HIS AGENDA THROUGH.
THE ECONOMY IS SOARING.
WE LOOK MUCH BETTER ON THE WORLD
STAGE.
TODAY HE MADE HIS ARGUMENT IN
SUPPORT OF THE GOP TAX PLAN
BACK.
JOINING US WITH REACTION COUNSEL
TO THE PRESIDENT KELLYANNE
CONWAY.
I WAS DOING ALL OF TRUMP'S
ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
DING, DING, DING.
THE MEDIA DOESN'T COVER THAT.
ALL OF THE REGULATIONS.
THIS IS A CORPORATE TAX CUT THAT
IS MASSIVE.
MIDDLE-CLASS TAX CUT.
THIS IS A BIG DEAL AND ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE.
MILLIONS OF JOBS WILL BE CREATED
ON AN ALREADY RECOVERING
ECONOMY.
>> TODAY WAS ONE OF THE MOST
EXCITING DAYS SINCE WE HAVE BEEN
HERE THIS YEAR.
YOU CAN SEE IT.
YOU CAN FEEL IT.
THE PRESIDENT WAS EXCITED TO
HOST FIVE FAMILIES WHO SEND HIS
INVITATION TO GO UP TO THE
PODIUM IN FRONT OF LIVE TV
CAMERAS AND TELL THEIR STORIES
UNSCRIPTED.
THEY THOUGHT LONG AND HARD ABOUT
WHAT THEY WOULD DO WITH EXTRA
MONEY IN THEIR POCKET.
THIS PRESIDENT IS STOPPING IT.
SOME IN HOME RENNOVATIONS.
OTHERS SAY THEY WOULD GIVE IT TO
REDUCING THAT CORPORATE RATE AND
BRINGING THOSE JOBS BACK FROM
OVERSEAS.
A CENTERPIECE OF PRESIDENT
THE ANTICIPATION HAS MEANT 17
YEAR HIGH IN CONSUMER
CONFIDENCE.
YESTERDAY WE SAW SMALL BUSINESS
GROUPS COMING OUT WITH THEIR
MEASUREMENTS.
WE ARE ON THE VERGE OF PASSING
HISTORIC TAX REFORM.
THE PRESIDENT SAID PEOPLE WOULD
SEE THE DIFFERENCE IN THEIR
PAYCHECKS IN FEBRUARY.
WHEN YOU FILE TAXES ON APRIL
15th, YOU WILL HAVE SEEN THE
DIFFERENCE IN THE PAYCHECKS.
HE IS THE PAYCHECK PRESIDENT.
>> Sean: YOU SAW WHAT HAPPENED
WITH ROSENSTEIN.
THEN YOU HAVE BRUCE OHR AND HIS
WIFE.
FUSION GPS.
HILLARY BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA THAT
INFLUENCED THE ELECTION.
YOU PUT ALL OF THIS TOGETHER AND
LOOK AT WHERE WE ARE, WHERE ARE
EVER SEEN THINGS AT THE TOP.
THEY ARE WORKING OVERTIME TO
HURT THIS PRESIDENT DAY IN AND
OUT.
>> THE PRESIDENT MADE VERY CLEAR
MANY TIMES THAT HE HAS A GREAT
DEAL OF FAITH IN THE
RANK-AND-FILE AT THE FBI AND
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES AND MAYBE
OF THE HARD WORKING MEN AND
WOMEN IN HIS GOVERNMENT.
AT THE SAME TIME, HE WANTS
INVESTIGATIONS TO BE INDEPENDENT
AND FAIR AND ACCOUNTABLE.
AMERICANS HAVE A RIGHT TO FEEL
DISTURBED WITH THAT THEY SEE IN
TEXT MESSAGES AND IN TERMS OF
PEOPLE'S POLITICAL MOTIVATIONS.
I AM GLAD THE INFORMATION AND
EVIDENCE IS GETTING OUT THERE.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE IN THE WHITE
HOUSE, IT SHOWS THE SPLIT SCREEN
WHAT HAVE IS GOING ON.
YOU SEE ALL OF THAT.
THIS INVESTIGATION ABOUT 2016
AND WE ARE BACK TO THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN.
WE CAN'T GET RID OF THEM.
I WOULD LOVE TO.
YOU SEE THE SPLIT SCREEN.
THE PRESIDENT TRUMP STANDING ON
THE VERGE OF TAX REFORM -- HE IS
ALSO DOING SOMETHING ELSE
TOMORROW.
HE WILL TALK ABOUT MASSIVE
DEREGULATION.
>> Sean: THAT'S HUGE.
>> HE PROMISED 2 REGULATIONS OUT
AND HE IS WAY AHEAD OF THAT.
>> Sean: KELLYANNE CONWAY, MERRY
CHRISTMAS.
YOU CAN SAY MERRY CHRISTMAS.